buddy time for new rule alright new rule
if cops want to appear less militarized
they have to lose those boots unless
you're getting your horse ready for the
steeplechase
let's admit that Jack boots are only
appropriate in two places neo Nazi
rallies and gay porn those are the only
new rule now that Isis has opened an
amusement park for kids
someone has to break it to them that
their image is still good to be somewhat
negative but meanwhile welcome to jihad
City the angriest place on earth where
you can visit yesterday land throw
stones at an adulterer to win a stuffed
bear and enjoy the photo booths that are
set up all over the park oh wait those
are the women
new rule squirrels need to calm the hell
down nobody wants your stupid acorns
okay plus you live in Southern
California winters not coming your nuts
are safer than Caitlyn Jenner's new rule
someone has to tell mr. bean that nobody
over here gives a damn anymore sorry mr.
bean new rule Scouts for major league
baseball teams have to stop ignoring the
Palestinian territories look at this
kids form I bet he throws ninety miles
an hour I didn't catch your name son but
how'd you like to stop throwing at Jews
and start throwing for one
and finally numeral primitive tribes
deep in the jungle who traditionally
object to Western intruders taking their
picture because they believe it steals
their soul are correct they were right
all along taking pictures of everything
absolutely does steal your soul look at
these idiots on a gondola in Venice
missing out on Venice look at this fool
lining up a picture of a bull about to
go ahead
look at these two dummies taking a
selfie at the pivotal moment of their
wedding ceremony there's a photographer
standing right behind you can't you put
your phone away and be fully present for
this you're getting married it might be
the last time you look into each other's
eyes and smile
yeah something deeply stupid is going on
in our culture and although I'm sure
there's a temptation on the part of
Millennials to say I just don't
understand it because I'm older no I
understand it it's not hard to
understand it's just [ __ ] stupid look
at these people they traveled thousands
of miles to take a shitty picture of the
Mona Lisa the most reproduced image in
the history of the world there's a
postcard of it in the gift shop
downstairs this is the actual Mona Lisa
look at it here's something even worse
and not just because the people in the
shop think a man in a white dress has
magical powers
no because they've got maybe 10 seconds
to actually see their hero and they're
choosing to give that up to view him
through a phone gosh if there only
existed some sort of professional whose
job it was to take great photos of a big
event so you could enjoy the moment we
could call them photograph
you know if I let the Pope I'd want to
look him in the eye I'd want to feel
those Pope Eve eyes I'd want to see if
he could make me cry like John Boehner
and look at this the Pope visited a
classroom and the kids were turning
their backs on him to take selfies
someone should have told those kids
you're never going to get another chance
to actually meet this man and also for
God's sake kids never turn your back on
a priest
you know virtual reality is great but
you know what virtual means it means
almost stop living in almost life walk
down any vibrant city street today and
you'll see hundreds of people ignoring
it while staring into their phones in
New York there's something interesting
to look at every three feet a street
performer a peddlers selling African art
a mime being murdered a rat carrying a
pizza Bill Cosby coming out of a
drugstore
chris Christie fighting a rat for a
pizza
and you want to look at your phone even
when people do actually get together
they're not all there half the time
you're out to dinner with people they
want the phone on the table just to
check okay something better comes in
happen to me the other night I was so
insulted
I could barely take pictures of the food
it would be like in the middle of
talking to you fine people if I was also
checking up on another audience and you
know most distressing of all polls show
that up to ten percent of people now
look at their phone during sex call me
old-fashioned but I still think that
during sex the handheld device should be
your dick what's next
texting the person you're actually
[ __ ] are you close no service how the
[ __ ] am I supposed to come now
you